[Music]
[Applause]
uh louis reddick joining us from
columbus ohio espn monday night football
analyst the pro day of justin
fields lewis thanks for joining us have
you ever seen a bad pro day
um no not really i mean i've seen i've
seen ones where
then you know maybe the players didn't
especially at quarterback
didn't perform maybe up to expectations
as far as some of their accuracy is
concerned
i think i believe teddy bridgewater's
pro day was one where people thought it
should be better than what it actually
was
but look i think look this is just these
are the kind of things that at this
time of year have some actual real-life
games being played that a lot of
importance is being attached to
as far as how guys look in these in
these environments and we know better
we know better than to put too much into
it but it's because we love this sport
so much we'll blow up anything man
and these and these are fun and it is
and i think in this environment in
particular dan
where people haven't seen each other in
a long time they just
want to like they want to be around
people they want to see these guys throw
and justin fields will put on a show
today what do you want to see out of a
quarterback
i think first and foremost you want to
see especially if he had mechanics
deficiencies whether it be with his with
his feet
with his release with the length of his
release you want to see
that kind of stuff get cleaned up here
and you want to see him be able to
repeat it over and over and over again
in the proper new and improved way if he
had
issues in that way and i think obviously
you want to see ball placement you want
to see accuracy you want to see velocity
those are the things you want to see and
and if that's what you're looking for in
particular today
justin fields has that in droves i mean
this guy can throw the football
as good if not better than any other
quarterback in this draft but what's the
issue
you know what i i think with it with him
it's this you know i think a lot of
times when quarterbacks come out of ohio
state
people have such respect for ryan day
and they believe that he is
such a masterful play caller and play
designer they want to know how much of
it is justin how much of it is ryan how
much is justin
really arctic you know how much is he
orchestrating at the line of scrimmage
as opposed to how much of it is ryan day
and people want to ask they want to know
questions about they want to have
answers rather to
what happened against northwestern what
happened against indiana is that
indicative
of a bigger problem or were those just
bad days i spent a lot of time talking
ryan day already this morning
and he answered those questions he said
look every quarterback gonna have a bad
day i mean and
the the play the play against indiana
like he said
justin was trying to win the heisman
trophy in that one game and he was
trying too hard
and you know and he's a human being he's
still a young quarterback so
if people want to just you know knock
him down because of it then you're going
to be missing out on what is really
a very unique and uniquely talented
individual
and i think we'll see that today how
many of these quarterbacks do you think
can start right away
you know i i never want to say that any
of them can really start right away
can they i guess they all can should
they i guess is the better question
right dan should they
did any of them start right away i think
obviously i think
you know the the arrows point towards
mack jones being the one who can start
right away because he's considered maybe
the most cerebral in terms of how much
responsibility steve sarkisian and nick
saban gave him
in the huddle at the line of scrimmage
and because the reason why they did that
is to make up for some of the athletic
limitations that he had as far as not
being able to create when things broke
down
mack had to play within the context of
that offense and he did it beautifully
so i think he's probably the one who
people think to be able to play
right away at a high level or at a
reasonably high level
but i would not discount any of these
other young men because they are
all very talented and all very smart
but it's it's we have these one year
wonders now
and i don't know how difficult it is you
know your
former executive you you're looking at
you know dwayne haskins one-year wonder
uh
tyler murray one year wonder you're just
not quite sure what you're getting there
zach wilson was competing to start at
byu
and here he is gonna be the second pick
overall like it's just
it's i don't know how you do enough
research where you go yep
yep that guy is real he's legit here uh
you know joe burrow
if he had come out his junior year he's
a fourth-round draft pick
he stays and has the greatest single
season of quarterbacks ever had and he's
the number one pick overall
matt jones we didn't even know who he
was he wasn't on anybody's
list and now he could be the third pick
overall
that's that's right that's a crazy
ascension with some of these
quarterbacks
yeah you know what i mean obviously a
lot of it i mean as you know dan is
supply and demand i mean you just you
have such limited supply of quarterbacks
every year
and the demand is so great to find that
next one that can
lead your team to the promised land but
i think getting back to how do you know
you really
don't know okay and any any scout or gm
who tells you that they do know for you
know with certainty that this guy's
gonna be great and this guy's not
they're lying and look all gm's and
scouts want to believe that they
invented football and they can tell
things that someone else can't
but really what it comes down to more
than anything
is what are the teams doing to help
these players succeed
as far as teaching progressions play
calling
surrounding cast i know people don't
want to hear that
because people just want to know that
they just want to believe that they're
gm smarter than the next guy
but really where the gm is going to
really set himself up to succeed is what
is he doing
as far as surrounding this young man and
what is the coaching staff doing
because i've seen it too many times as a
player and i've seen it in the front
office too
i've seen players get ruined because
their coaching was just not up to par
and everyone believes that across all 32
teams that coaching is equal and you
know better it's not
it's just not and that doesn't that's
not to be disrespectful that's just the
truth
and some of these guys will be better
served going some places as opposed to
other places
it just fit matters for these
quarterbacks so until you can tell me
all of that i can't tell you with
certainty who's going to be better than
the next guy
do you think that zach wilson is better
than sam darnold
i think he's physically you know from a
throwing perspective he's more talented
he's naturally more talented throwing
the football
okay and you can see that but it's the
nfl
jamarcus who was more talented throwing
people than demarcus russell right
not many and for this matter look i came
on your show
and i told you i believe that dwayne
haskins was a phenomenal talent i still
do
but it isn't just about how you throw
the football it's how you conduct
yourself how you study how you commit
yourself
what the coaches are like how much are
they invested in you how much do they
believe in you what kind of play calling
do they
subject you to that's really where
that's where the money is made and
that's where these guys wind up
separating themselves but louis how do
you investigate work ethic
if you're a front office exactly because
that to me i go back to
the equipment guy at washington state
was telling me about ryan leaf and he
said he doesn't love football you know
and and he turned you know it turned out
to be true that he didn't love football
he was good at football
he just didn't love football how do you
do an investigative
search there to find out if somebody
truly loves the game
yeah you know some of it's going to be
you know your instinctive gut feel when
you have one-on-one interviews with a
certain individual and you're
based off of your past experiences does
a certain guide develop or rather
exhibit the kind of behavior that you've
seen
other guys who are invested to that
degree exhibit
some of it's going to be word of mouth
and i'm really having to trust
the kind of sources that you're talking
about whether it be the equipment guy
the grounds crew guy the security guy
who saw this guy showing up at 4 35 a.m
in the morning before anyone else did
putting into work in the summer when
everyone else was on vacation
you're gonna take all of that to really
try to ascertain whether or not somebody
truly
loves football and and then
you're never going to be a hundred
percent on it but guys
i mean just like whether it's football
or anything else dan i mean people you
you know i mean people who perform at a
high level who are
unique in their chosen profession
exhibit
unique traits and habits as far as their
dedication to their craft
and you can pick out the ones who really
do stand out
and the ones who really do love it and
some of those guys who are on the fence
hey i guess you try and stay away from
them but you're just trying to really
you're just trying to line things up
line the dominoes up enough to where you
reasonably feel
that this guy is not going to bust out
on you because he didn't love the game
that's all you're trying to do and it's
an imperfect science
and that's why every year we have these
discussions he's louis redick the former
player espn monday night football
analyst all right give me the logic
behind what the niners are doing with
this draft pick
and with jimmy yeah i think
for sure that they they feel as though
out you know other than trevor lawrence
and zach wilson
they like their pick of trey lance
justin fields or matt jones they're
comfortable with
with one of those three um and they feel
as though putting
you know getting up to that number three
spot given what they gave up
puts them in a position where they're
gonna set themselves up for the future
with jimmy g look i he's a high high
high
high priced bridge quarterback right now
is what he is
he's a placeholder it's as simple as
that
and the way kyle talked about it
yesterday look
they want him to be the placeholder they
would like for their young quarterback
to not have to play right away
but if you make him an offer that he
likes he will send him to you meaning
jimmy garoppolo
he'll send them to you and i think you
know as chris sims has alluded to and
different people have alluded to
the only way that you would really
consider sending jimmy down the road is
because you feel as though the young
quarterback that you're going to draft
you have a reasonable chance of getting
him ready to play right now with a
roster that he thinks can win a super
bowl
and that's why people are connecting the
dots to matt jones because they feel as
though
he's the guy who'll be ready to play the
fastest it's a fascinating
fascinating puzzle to try and put
together and
that's what's going to make this whole
month so intriguing because
athletically mack knows himself he's not
on the same level as trey lansing dustin
because he knows that
but he also knows this when we talk
about quarterbacks busting out of the
league dan
it's usually because of what's going on
from the neck up isn't it it has nothing
to do with how he performed in a pro day
nothing to do with how he flipped his
hip from through the ball across field
going against the grain it had to do
with something that just was not
connecting upstairs and matt jones no
one has that issue with
so is san francisco really crazy for
moving up to number three to pick him
i guess we'll find out yeah but when did
jimmy g stop being kyle shanahan's type
of quarterback because i'm assuming we
keep hearing about kyle shanahan's type
of quarterback
you traded for him you know like he
wasn't there when you got there you
traded for him
it's like sean mcvay had jared goff he
was your quarterback
and then all of a sudden he's we don't
blame the coach
we always blame the player absolutely
and you know what i think when you're
dealing with human beings
who have changing opinions and changing
you know
mindsets towards certain individuals i
think you have to be you have to prepare
yourself for
for people to basically change their
minds and go in a different direction
and not
i don't know what the moment is or what
what the moment was for kyle where he
felt like i needed to go in a different
direction
but i think it's an accumulation of
things over time that he watched
i'm sure that super bowl probably stings
in many different ways against kansas
city where
you know he has emmanuel sanders
streaking open in the middle of the
field and jimmy overthrows him
which really that would have won in the
football game they probably win that
game and he hits that throw
but do you think he's still the
quarterback if they win that super bowl
is jimmy g
that doesn't make any sense at all no no
no no no i was listening to what you
were saying but
i know where you were going with it
doesn't do i think he's still the
quarterback yeah he won that super bowl
i don't know it's jared goff still the
quarterback if the rams win the super
bowl like
is it that tenuous i mean i i i you know
what that that's a great question
that's a great question you just said is
it that tenuous i believe now
in the nfl it is that tenuous because
now
everything is so hyper analyzed and
patience
is not something that's at a premium
anymore it's just this i mean you saw
look what happened to carla murray
and josh rosen in consecutive years they
took quarterbacks in the first in
consecutive
years what i mean 20 years ago you would
have been like that guy's getting fired
that gm's added
but now that that just shows you the
mindset has changed man and people will
flip
like that how many teams are there today
that you're aware of
all of from what i hear all of them
except the rounds
the rams are the only team not there
really what i've heard
but no i can't confirm that but i know
that i did hear that that may be the
only team that's not here
louis always great to talk to you have
fun today safe travels and
thanks for joining us absolutely thanks
for having me as always
that's a lewis riddick from the
mothership their monday night football
and